الهدوء وعداء الى شوارع العاصمه الصينيه
بعد كبح عده مظاهرات مساء يوم الاثنين
الشرطه الصينيه ملات شوارعلى عاصمه بكين
واشنغهايه
جديده ضد السياسه صفر كوميدي التي تنتهجها
الحكومه لا اعتقد ان الوباء بهذه الخطوره
برايي نجحت الصين في السيطره على الوباء
بشكل جيد لكن مع الطقس البارد ستشهد
البلاد موجه جديده هذا طبيعي اعتقد ان
الاعداد ستنخفض بعد فتره وجيزه
رغم رفض المواطنين للقيود الصحيه الصارمه
وطبات النمو الاقتصادي في البلاد اعلانات
السلطات الصينيه عن اتخاذ اجراءات اضافيه
لمكافحه الوباء في ظل ارتفاع عدد المصابين
بشكل قياسي
تتجاوز اعمارهم 80 عاما ومواصله زياده
معدل التطعيم للبالغين ما بين 60 او 79
عاما
ورغم الدعوات الغربيه
والسماحه بالتظاهر السلمي تم اعتقال بعض
المحتاجين واجرك قوات وانفاذ القانون
اتصالاتها للحصول على المعلومات حول
التحركات كما تلقت العديد من الحالات امرا
بالاغلاق قبل الساعه العاشره مساء